good morning everyone so um now let's
let's get started with uh lecture seven
already from this class from this course
so today I'm gonna be talking to you
about the domain one of the first
domains after Petter I describe the sets
and the graphs and this domain is
degrades
um so
just as a recap to set the tone and to
to remember where where we are coming
from so um we I mean yesterday you saw
or yesterday to go from better one of
the first ways to think about this
blueprint practice when the input is has
some set structure or some structure and
we probably have seen that there's many
already a lot of different varieties of
flavors that appear right and better
describe this to you
so in this lecture we are gonna go and
zoom in into the one particular domain
that maybe from for historical reasons
has been very important very Central
which is the great right that is kind of
underpainting many of the successes of
the neural networks in computer vision
and speech processing Etc
and we are going to see that in this
domain we can say things that are pretty
pretty precise and and there's a there's
a lot of interesting mathematical
structure that one can develop in this
domain so uh today yeah it's a it's
going to be a pretty um I'm I'm hoping
to keep things in one hour but it's it
might be like a long lecture so please
also like uh interrupt me if I if you
see that I'm taking too long so we are
going to first uh describe uh the
translation Group which is kind of the
natural group of Transformations that
appears in the in these grids and then
we're gonna
together see how to think about this
group uh through what we call Fourier
transforms right so the Fourier
transforms we have a good way to
understand what's happening with this
group
then we are gonna take some of these
like principles and be all the
convolutional neural network from first
principles right we've had many many
bells and whistles this is the
scattering web electron form and then
we're gonna see uh how you know from
these elements we can now describe and
arrive naturally at the convolutional
neural networks the last part of the
lecture
all right so let's get started with uh
with the first part of the of the
lecture
so as you all know like a grids are
defined I mean they have these uh very
very regular structure and the natural
grips grids that you like that you know
grids have a essentially one parameter
which is uh the dimension in which they
live right so in one dimension you have
a you know a grid you can think it has a
line that is like sampled in a way that
is uniform so that's the kind of domain
that you think when you are describing
uh same time series like you know speech
data even text data or financial data in
two Dimensions we have this natural
structure this like a rectangular like
Square lattice that of course is the one
that you use for treating images
and so um once I told you it's like the
an important kind of concept is once I
give you this physical domain what is
this is the transformation what are the
things that I can do to move stuffs and
move things in the domain so in this
integrative if you start with a simplest
case that is like a one you know one
dimensional grid well the you know the
only basically the only thing that comes
to mind in terms of like when I need to
move things around is to basically just
shift things around right so so the idea
is that if I if I try to think you know
taking a single point and moving it well
the the you know the point can move you
know from one part of the domain to the
other and you know the the natural thing
you might say okay what happens when
it's in the boundary right so when when
the when the point is at the boundary it
needs to change direction well here we
do a little mathematical trick that is
okay just for convenience what we are
going to do is that we are going to
invent you know this what we call
periodic boundary condition right so
what we are saying is that um
uh we are making this this domain into
something that has no boundary right uh
every time so when this point arrives at
the at the end it starts again okay and
so um the reason for this is mostly like
mathematical convenience as you will see
right away uh because now we can try to
to you know
I instant like to to think about this in
intuitively but now we can also try to
express it mathematically okay so the
operation of moving you know one point
around this domain okay can be written
in a very in a very natural form right
is that I can I can now think about this
transformation as a bijection right so
it's a mapping that goes from the domain
to itself
and what it takes is that takes any
coordinate you right so U would be kind
of indexing this point here and it just
moves it to the right okay and you can
see that the only thing that seems like
a little bit uh you know non-standard
here is that we look at this we think
about this addition in the modular
arithmetic right so um I don't know how
many people here in the in the crowd is
familiar with the modular arithmetic
right this is just think about this like
integers but once you arrive at the you
know the integer number D this is
equivalent to zero right so you start
again
and so you can think this as a function
G as well as a transformation and now we
can do many interesting things right so
once I have a once I know how to what is
that information that moves everything
to the right I can say okay what is the
information that moves everything to the
left right so I can undo the
transformation well we write this as G
minus one because it's kind of the
inverse right of moving things to the
right is moving things to the left and
so you can see how nice you know this
periodic structure is because now we can
just you know just just replace plus one
by minus one right then we take
everything
arithmetic and uh you know everything is
is still well defined and not only we
can just consider the inverse we can
also
that can I Ask Annie to mute okay
perfect I mean so so I can take the
inverse of a transformation but I can
also take powers of a transformation
right so so maybe maybe you already
figure out what it means G to the K
right so G to the K means instead of
moving uh things for one element to the
right it means moving them K elements to
the right right so like I'm applying the
motion K times
all right
so this is what we call algebraic
structure and this is also what the Taco
uh could capture captured in his lecture
this is really the structure of the
group right like these Transformations
they look like functions right but you
can think about these mappings as also
living in a group right and so I think I
can take a mapping and I can consider
its inverse mapping I can take a mapping
two mappings from that group and I can
multiply them together okay this is what
we call this algebraic structure
okay and actually the group we already
encounter it before when we're looking
at the examples last week this is called
the cyclic group okay it's really the
group of uh integers modology
all right uh so this is something that
you can Define for the the Grid in one
dimension but uh you can also do the
exactly the same thing when the grid has
more dimensions for example when we are
treating with images right we don't have
just a single line of pixels we have a
like a you know two-dimensional array
right so in that case the domain is just
uh essentially what we call a product
right it's like a tensor product of the
two groups that we see before right so
here the group of Transformations is
just like the product of the two groups
right yes so here the number of copies I
put captures exactly the number of
dimensions of the domain okay so if I'm
looking for images my group of
Transformations would be Z times Z right
and if I'm looking at videos for example
where I have three copy you know like
three dimensions and I would have three
versions of them
uh you can also do the same thing in
continuous domain right so instead of
thinking about your grid like your
domain by just having like like a
discrete number of positions like pixels
we can think a bit more abstractly and
say that in fact you know my my data is
just living in a continuous grid right
so you know I can I can think about
images as your eye like your retina
right I don't have pixels right you know
it seems more like a continuous thing so
here's the same thing right so the the
domain
is a kind of a download like a Taurus
and so the group of transformations of
this domain here in that case correspond
to the kind of the continuous version of
this cyclic groups right which is just
the the group of basically the reals
with modular arithmetic as well
okay there's a one curious like a
interesting aspect in these examples
right is that in that case you can see
that the the domain
and the group of Transformations they
seem to be equivalent right in the sense
that uh I can uh you know there's a
one-to-one correspondence between a
pixel in my domain and a transformation
in this like group of Chiclet chips
right this is really this is not the
rule this is more like an exception
right so you are going to see a next
lecture by Taco that in general it's not
necessarily the case right like the
group of transformations in a domain and
the domain might not be the same you
know might not be the same right but
this is an important kind of property of
grids
okay and so remember
that uh also what we said is that once
we have once we know how to move things
in our domain
we can use it to move signals in the
domain right the the idea that if I now
if I know how to move pixels right now
you give me an image which would be kind
of a map over the pixels I can also move
this image yeah and so the way we do it
is by by basically doing the composition
right what we saw last time
okay and one of the one of the important
and here's a kind of a little
illustration that shows you know if I
have like some shifts in my in my domain
I can use it to move images around right
and one of the important features right
of this uh lifting is that now this
transformation that acts on the signals
is linear
okay so this mapping here G that is now
defined over X not over the mega this
mapping is linear
so what does it mean if I have a mapping
that is linear
I can think about it right as a matrix
right like a you know a linear
transformation from one domain to itself
I can think it as a matrix right if this
X here you can take it as a vector space
okay and so what I mean here is that if
now we go back to our case of when we
have the Grid in one dimension that we
had the pixels I can think about the
spaces of signals here as having a d
degrees of freedom right so I can think
it as a vector space of Dimension d
right which is very well here I have D
pixels
so I have a Transformations that are
linear
that take as input the D dimensional
including space
so what I'm saying is that you can think
of this as a matrix right so like this
transformation that I'm describing here
I can take it as a matrix so what is
this Matrix
so this Matrix is what we call the shift
operator
okay so remember this is a matrix that
is now size d times d right it's like
the number of pixels of the domain so
and so it has it's almost zero like it's
zero almost everywhere except for some
ones that are just above the diagonal
right so here I have all these ones and
then I have a last one here in the
corner
yeah
so read this one in the corner you know
if you wonder why why do we have this
kind of little guy here by itself
remember this is kind of the boundary
condition right so this tells me that
when I'm in the you know in the last
coordinate right it I'm going to be sent
I'm going to send the last coordinate to
the first coordinate this is saying that
I'm going to send the coordinate that is
in position I to the position I plus one
right that's what we are just above the
react
okay
and so now we can transform this kind of
algebraic structure into basically
operations with matrices right so you
told me that if I have a transformation
right this is the the shift operator if
I apply it K times
well what is associated metrics it's
just taking this Matrix and multiplying
it times k
all right so this as you might imagine
it's going to shift this diagonal right
it's going to move it above and it's
going to move
and so here's what I just size for you
is that okay now that I have this
representation I can think about this
transformation as applying this Matrix
you can maybe use this fact to show that
this group is commutative right so if I
apply two Transformations and I compose
them I get the same thing
okay
you can think about about this question
yeah and then you can use this this
exercise here you can use this this
property
all right
and there's another remark if you want
to kind of understand why you know where
does this object come from is that you
could also have seen about the seen this
differently by looking at this domain
right and now just try let's try to
think of this as a graph okay so we're
we're going to build a directed graph
that basically tells us that this node
is mapped to this node right so we put
an arrow here and if I can draw here I
cannot draw
maybe I can try to draw let's see if
that works
draw
okay so I put an arrow here then I put
another arrow here right I put an arrow
here
Etc right
this is really again illustrating what
this transformation is doing right it's
just mapping it's just moving things
around to in a certain direction right
and this guy goes here
okay so if I wrote The adjacency Matrix
of this graph I get exactly this uh
these shift operator
okay
good let me continue
okay let me just erase this erase
sorry clear oh
okay
perfect
and so
now that we have this metrics
let's go to the kind of the the key
question right is that and this is
really uh
is really uh you know
building from the from the blueprint
that we described together last week
okay so remember that the the geometric
deep learning blueprint is really asking
us to it's it's a procedure that it's
going to build very powerful
representation like neural networks from
a very simple structure by understanding
The Operators that are linear and that
are invariant and equivalent with
respect to the action of the group right
so we need to understand how to compute
linear invariant and equivalence okay so
now we have the group which is the group
of shifts right in this in this domain
and so the question for for that we are
gonna that we are gonna study now
together is how to build linear
invariant and equivalence
all right
so again and and for Simplicity we are
gonna We Are Gonna consider the case
where we have one dimensional grid and
we are going to have uh you know like a
d pick stocks okay so we are in another
so let's start with the linear
invariance okay so remember what is a
linear invariant is a linear mapping
that goes from r d to R
that has the property that if I apply
this mapping these are these are linear
this this mapping to any transform
version of X I have to get exactly the
same thing
that's the property of being involved
so if it's a linear map that goes from
RT to R
I can always express it as a DOT product
right it's a definition all the linear
forms right are DOT products you know
and so what it means is that if I want
to characterize this linear invariant I
just need to characterize this vector v
but I need to find you know the vector v
such that if I Define this dot product I
need to have the property right that
when I apply my transformation right to
that is my transform version my mapping
to transform version of G I apply the
definition so this is just G times x dot
product with v and now by applying the
fact that g times x I told you that is
just this Matrix up to some power
applied to X
and V and now applying the transpose
right so I I arrive with the property
that a linear invariant is characterized
by some vector v such that for any X if
I look at the dot product between X and
this s k like this Matrix transpose
apply to B I need to get exactly X
transpose x dot product okay for any X
and for any k
all right
so if you look at this equation
what can we deduce immediately
so this puts some very important
constraint on V right V has to have this
property right that needs to satisfy
this for any X
so it's not hard to see right that uh
this is only going to happen if and only
if V has the property that V equals to S
times V
okay
and every time I have something here on
purple is really meant to be an exercise
for you right uh so the and and you can
see it right is that uh you know because
this is true for any X right these two
vectors you know this guy and this guy
have to be equal for any K in particular
for k equals one okay and you get you
get this basically this property here
okay and so when you look at this
equation what do you see right I have a
I need to find v such that V equals to S
times V
so if you have seen this equation
uh so this really is uh what we call an
eigenvalue problem right we are trying
to we are trying to characterize v as
being a negant vector of s right the
eigenvector is just a vector such that s
times G is a is a multiple of B right so
this is then this is the eigenvector
of s that has eigenvalue 1.
okay
and so because this s is a very special
Matrix right it's an adjacency Matrix of
this like a SQL graph in fact uh it's
it's not hard to see that the only V
that has satisfies this equation is the
V that is just a constant Vector right
all one vector
okay or any multiple of the all one
factor
and this is really uh if you have seen a
little bit of a Markov chain Monte Carlo
this is really based on what we call
what's called a Peron for business
theorem right it's just a it's a very
powerful result from linear algebra that
characterizes the largest uh so like the
eigenvector associated with the largest
taken value of a class of matrices right
that uh that are basically adjacency
matrices of certain graphs
all right
anyway V equals one is the is the only
solution
what it means that we have basically uh
you know figure out that the only linear
invariant right if we now we go back
here right what do you get if you just
uh you know have V that is the all one
vector a DOT product with X and all
one's Vector is just the sum like of the
average right so this is the recovering
what we suspected right that the only
linear invariant to to shift is just
taking the sum of the average of the
vector okay that's the linear
environment
okay now let's go to something slightly
more complicated which is
the not just the characterizing
invariants but characterizing
equivalents
right any questions so far on what I
just described
okay I see that there's no questions on
the chat
good
okay
I see that you are typing
okay we're gonna pause
all good
ah let me see
there are questions campus wire can you
um
okay
let's can we can you copy them here for
any chance
let me try to
foreign
to see if I can do it in parallel
okay I will while you try to type the
question I will also try to log into
campus buyer ah good there I am
okay
foreign
how do you compute
G minus 1
G minus 1 of the first element
ah
yeah so if I understood the question
correctly is how do you compute the
inverse right of a orbital of a shift in
in the one degree
good so the inverse it's really you can
really think about there's two ways
where you can think about it is that if
you have if you will if you are
if you trust me that I can name code
this uh you know like this
transformation to the right with the
shift operator which is this Matrix that
has ones just above the diagonal and
then the one last one in the in the left
corner
then you can just formally take the
inverse of this Matrix right
just invert The Matrix right The Matrix
is invertible that's one way to think
about it the other way to think about it
is well at the end of the day uh you
know deciding to the G is like a like a
you know shifting things towards the
right and then so you know that the
inverse of this is going to be shifting
things toward the left right at the end
of the day lie right and left is just
arbitrary right so it's just a way to
actually draw the arrows in my cyclic in
my you know in my in my uh under
directed graph right so you could also
uh just reverse the arrows right of the
shift and then compute The adjacency
Matrix of this operator
so at the end of in any of the two cases
right what you would get is essentially
the same Matrix G minus one is a matrix
that essentially has just like a like a
reversed thing right so like the you
know like instead of having one above
the diagonal you have once under the
diagonal and then the one that is in the
that was in the bottom left corner now
it's finding the upper right corner
right that's G minus one
all right and I'm trying to see if I can
uh
log into compost wire so that I can also
ask questions uh like answer questions
in real time
okay
see if I can make it work
well I'll try it again doesn't work
can you repeat what is s
s
ah here here in these uh you mean in
these um okay yes
in this formula you mean s capital S is
this Matrix that I have here I will show
you again
s is this Matrix
okay
so when I say S1 right it means just s
right but then the point right is that
the the fact that I uh I had here right
is that any transformation any shift
I can I can view it as taking a certain
power of this Matrix right just because
this is really a property of this cyclic
Group which is called a it's called
transitive property right like any
element of the group can be generated by
taking this kind of so the thing about
this like the basic building block right
so if I understand this of this Matrix
here
I'm I'm in business because I can then
generate any transformation in my group
right just by taking a certain part and
I can also take inverts right I can take
you know this K can be negative right
and this would be the inverse right
okay
good
so hopefully uh we are okay in terms of
the invariant right this is just the you
know the sum now let's hi in which case
can we use S to Decay yeah so SK so when
I say when I say um
you know as to the gay right is so it's
a metrics right that you can take Powers
right and and uh and so uh uh you are
totally safe to use like s to the K
transpose right like I hear the star
right corresponds to the transpose right
this is just uh you know in linear
aldera when you have a here I don't know
if you see my cursor right so when I
have a DOT product
and I have some like linear
transformation times x with v i can view
this dot product by sending this Matrix
here to the other side with the
transpose
okay I put the star just because it's
the same it's thing so think about these
stars that transpose right you can take
the Matrix and then transpose
good
okay now let's
um let's go to the next level
so instead of looking at invariants now
we need to look at equivalence
okay so now and and still like the key
point is that we are still looking at
just linear objects right we are just
need to understand what are the linear
transforms that are equivalent to
translations
okay so now if I have a linear key
variant it's a mapping the leader is
linear that goes from RD to Rd
okay so a mapping that is linear that
goes from RT to Rd
we have to think about it as a matrix
right now instead of being a vector that
was like this dot product now it's a
matrix that is a d by D Matrix
and this Matrix has the property right
that if I apply this operator to the
transform region of X I want to get
the same answer but then transform right
so in other words The Matrix have to
commute
with the action of the group
okay and so if we try to think about
this as some Matrix with some Matrix C
right so this is the the the operator
that I want to characterize
what I want right is that if I apply
this Matrix to some shifted version of
the input and remember that shifts I can
think about them as applying this shift
operator for a certain number of times
right that's that's by definition then I
need to get something that commits right
so again by the same logic as before
what what this condition is equivalent
to asking that this Matrix that I'm
looking for has to commute
with a shift right so I'm looking I need
to find all the matrices C such that c
times s is equal to S times C
okay is it is this clear this I I want
to make sure that people are happy with
this fact because this is kind of an
important profit right and we are going
to spend a few minutes together
trying to understand the consequences of
that okay so this is really the property
of equivalence right that I I want to be
I want I want to understand
what are the
linear Transformations like in that case
are going to be matrices that commute
with translations and because
translations can be expressed through
this shift operator this this is the you
know in the language of matrices this is
just expressed as two matrices that
commit with each other
all right so now let's try to understand
that right
okay
we need to characterize these matrices
so
here
so the question I have really is I give
a you know I know this Matrix S and I
want to understand everything that
commute with s
so in terms of for understanding this
question well it turns out that I need
to do is to understand
kind of the spectral properties of this
Matrix S
okay and so
let's try to formalize a little bit this
this intuition okay so uh yeah I told
you that the I joined like the transpose
right is acting is looks like it's the
actual the inverse right like the
transposing S is the same as inverting s
okay so you know in that sense it means
that if I apply s transpose times s is
equal to S as transposer is the identity
okay so this what it means is that this
Matrix S is what we call a normal Matrix
right normal matrices are have this
property right that you can you know as
times as transpose equals to the
identity
and so what it means is that I can think
I can extract its eigenvectors and eigen
Bulbs right like uh so this class of
matrices for this kind of matrices I can
you know it makes sense to compute the
the Spectrum
so let's try to do that okay so what we
need is that we need to find
eigenvectors and eigenvalues of s
so here's a here's a vector for U right
I'm gonna I'm gonna Define this
complicated looking Vector right and and
I don't know if you can see the picture
in the bottom right which is kind of
trying to illustrate
what I'm what I'm writing here in
equation right so this is I'm
considering a vector v that has an
actual vectors are called V K
so for h k is a vector in dimension D
that is a vector that is very special
because it's complex value right it's
not a real Vector it's complex value and
why do I need complex vectors instead of
real vectors
this is because this Matrix S right it's
not symmetric right and so the the you
know in general the eigenvectors and
eigenvalues of matrices that are
non-tometric might be complex right and
that's our situation here
anyway it's a vector that it's expressed
through complex exponentials
and so complex exponentials is nothing
else right then Sines and cosines right
so basically you know the real part is
is a cosine here and the imaginary part
is a sign right and so what I'm doing is
I'm basically varying the frequency of
you know every entry right I have D
different entries every entry has a
different frequency and this is why this
is why I'm kind of drawing here right
you have to think that each one of these
vectors right corresponds to one of
these waves right and instead of having
just one wave I have you know the real
part and the imaginary part are two
different waves that are slightly
shifter one from each other
okay so now let's try to look at that
dot product between uh The Matrix S and
uh and one of these vectors right so if
I look at the dot product between the
between uh you know the jth row of s and
one of these vectors
this is just basically uh by definition
this is looking at the you know Shifting
the entry of the vector v by one
and so you can write that if you if you
shift the you know if you evaluate this
Vector at location J plus 1 right like
for example comparing this guy with this
guy right you can you can see that this
is just uh
foreign
basically this is just uh evaluating the
vector at the initial location times
something that does not depend on J
right this is just like the shift that
is that is here
all right I think there was an error
this is just uh yeah so this is J right
so basically I can I can think about
this as extracting you know like the
entries J here it has the same thing the
same argument but instead of having a j
it has a j minus one right so I can
think about J minus J as you know taking
out one element like this times the same
thing with a J minus one right which is
exactly This this term here anyway so
what I have what I have what I have here
is that I can verify that if I take you
know if I take this vector and I do s
times this Vector I get a multiple of v
k okay and the eigenvalue Lambda K is
exactly this quantity that you have here
right the eigenvalue is uh e to the
you know e to the i 2 pi K Over d okay
so I have a essentially given you the
eigenvectors of s
okay uh if you don't trust me you can
try to you can you can do this uh you
know you can verify this operation by
yourself but it's really just what is
written in this equation okay and in
fact these are all the eigenvectors of s
right there's no other you know all the
eigenvectors of s are really these
complex explanations
okay
and so there's this is nothing else and
the Fourier transfer right I don't know
if you have you're familiar with Fourier
transforms but basically if I collect
all the vectors that I just given to you
and I put them in a matrix V right and
now I can define a transformation that
is also linear transformation that takes
any X and computes its all these dot
products with all these vks right that's
what's called a Fourier transform right
so in coordinate I can just look at x
dot product with VK for for all the
different case right here and I get all
these you know funny looking expression
so this Fourier transform has many many
cool properties I mean it's really uh
you know a very Central Tool in many
areas of mathematics and Engineering
okay so we uh if you look at the dot
product between two signals after the
Fourier transform you you get exactly
the same thing as before right that's
what's called an isometry or a more you
know it also has the name of a Percival
identity
we can we can take this transformation
and we can invert it write this Matrix V
here is invertible okay so you can
actually invert it very easily and go
back from the Fourier transform to the
original domain you can go back by this
linear transformation as well
okay and you can Define it for for our
particular setting when you have like a
d you know D pixels but there's many
many other domains in which you can
still Define free transforms right
whenever even if the condom is
continuous if the domain is kind of all
the real numbers many many many many
things right and probably you know you
you will probably see foreign form for
many years to come right if you're still
like involved in you know enriches in
many areas and for example just you know
not to go very far uh you know last week
there was the fields medal right the
2022 and amongst the four first
medalists two of them
you know are doing kind of central like
the central tool that they use is
basically Fourier transforms okay so
this is really uh you know something
that is still quite important in many
many areas of math okay but the question
for us is how do we care why do we care
about this right so what is the link
between Fourier transforms and our
problem of characterizing the
equivalents right like The Operators
that commute with translations
well let's back to our question right so
what we want is to understand operators
see that commute with s
okay so there's a there's a an important
property from linear algebra right
that I can use to characterize matrices
to matrices commutes
even only if they have something you
know there's some relationship between
the eigenvectors of one and the vectors
of the other I don't know if someone
remembers that
it turns out that if I want two matrices
to commute
I need to ask them to have to share the
same eigenvectors
okay they can have different eigenvalues
but they need they need to share the
same again vectors right this is the
equivalent to asking the two matrices to
commit
okay this is a
kind of a an important exercise right in
linear algebra
okay
and so uh what a what uh what this means
for us right is that the medicine the
equivalent maps that I'm trying to
characterize are precisely those that
whose eigenvectors are free like the the
vectors that we just described that were
the eigenvectors of s okay so in other
words all the metrics is C that once I
might once I'm in the Fourier domain
they are diagonal okay these are exactly
the maps that I'm looking for
okay
so I can characterize them with some
vector
you know Alpha that is basically the
what is in the diagonal of this Matrix
so this this is complex because we are
in this you know complex domain and this
gives me all the maps directly by but
what do they you know what are these
maps about right I mean how can we think
about these Maps perhaps in the spatial
domain not in the freedom
okay so this is really the One Step that
I'm gonna just do it together right it's
uh you know maybe it's good to do it at
least once
so let's try to date okay here's a
here's three equations that I'm gonna
try to to describe to you in a little
bit of detail but I I wrote here three
equations let's try to understand this
first equation what does it say
I'm just taking I'm just taking X right
and I'm writing it in terms of its
Fourier atoms
okay
so here what I'm using right is the
inverse Fourier transform okay so I can
I can express X in terms of its Fourier
coefficients
second equality is uh using the fact
that c is linear
okay
C is linear so it means that the C
applied to a linear combination of
vectors right is that I can put the C
inside
okay
and the third equation
is using exactly what I what I what we
have here right is that c applied to any
Fourier coefficient it's going to be
it's gonna so this V K is going to be an
eigen Vector of C
okay that's because C needs to share the
same eigenvectors as s right so that's
the third equation okay so just to to
refresh right so these are the three
properties that we are using so far okay
okay
now we are almost there there's two more
equations
okay now let's try to do that now let's
try to write what we have in this
equation in coordinates right so let's
write it in coordinates okay so let's
look at let's look at the jth coordinate
of this Vector right so the just because
of this Vector here by this equation
it's just basically looking at the jth
coordinate of v k transpose okay
and so
if you do that and you do some
rearrangements right you can you can
write that the jth coordinate by by you
know by expressing the jth coordinate of
v k it's exactly this property here
right and now I can put the transpose
outside right so I can uh you know I can
massage this thing a little bit and I
have something a little bit funny
looking here right so I have a you know
the Fourier transform of X transpose at
frequency k
multiply by this complex exponential and
all these things transpose all this
thing conjugates times Alpha K transpose
so I can I can actually I can write this
as a DOT product between the Fourier
transform like this Alpha hat and
something that involves the shift of x
okay of X bar because this is conjugate
okay but the point is that now we here
we have two more properties right is
that we are using in this first equation
something that we didn't cover here but
it's a it's a kind of also like another
Elementary property of Fourier
transforms is that if I know how to
compute the four transform of a signal
then if I shift the signal the Fourier
transform the Fourier coefficients are
just multiplied by what we call this
kind of complex exponentials right here
we are just changing the phase right so
this is what we have here okay we are
you know this this quantity here is in
fact the Fourier transform of X with
applying some shift
and then the last thing that we are
doing right is remember is that the dot
products in the Fourier space are equal
to the dot products in the space in the
space like in the in the original domain
okay this is what we call the pastival
and now we are to a point where we can
you know we can we we can we look at
this equation right and this makes a lot
of sense right what I'm saying is that
this mapping here
C of X at location J I can see it as a
linear combination of shifted version of
X apply multiply by some filter
so this might look familiar to you right
what is this operation right when I'm
just uh you know taking a sum of shifted
versions of a signal times some weight
well that's in the title right that's
the convolution
all right
okay so just to summarize
what we have done here kind of for from
first principles
is just to realize right that any
operator that is equivalent right so
that commutes with shift is a
convolution
okay and in fact we can say something
more than that is that any convolution
commutes with this right because uh you
know if I write a convolution like this
right now I apply a shift to the input
right I can see that you know because
this thing is linear right uh a
convolution is a linear combination of
shifts
so uh you know because the shift is
available in group then I'm going to
write everything commutes everything is
fine
okay
so we have essentially characterized all
the linear equivalent Maps it was a
little bit uh you know we had to take a
little detour and talk about Fourier
transforms but uh at the end of the day
we end up with something that is pretty
digestible which is something that maybe
you already knew right the fact that
convolutions are exactly the maps that
are linear and they are equivalent
okay and I mean this is a picture a
little diagram that we that we have that
kind of summarizes everything that we
just said right is that you know if I
think about convolutions right I can see
that think about them in a special
domain with this kind of Matrix right
that is a has this like a top lid or
like a band structure and if I if I view
this operator this this mapping in the
Fourier domain now they need to be
diagonal right just because the the
Fourier domain is the one that
diagonalizes the shift
okay
very good so now uh I asked the question
well we have characterized this linear
equivalent Maps right which are
convolutions are all convolutions
equally good right it's like is
convolution everything we need
okay can I take any filter here that I
want right
with the natural questions
okay so what am I gonna argue now in
this slide is that we need to be a
little bit careful right it's not as
easy
and here's why
here so far we have just focused on
Transformations that basically move all
the pixels at the same time right when
we think about this shift right we are
moving everything one pixel two pixels
right but all the image right is going
to be moves you know together okay
here's a question that I'm asking is
what happens for transformation that are
a little bit more General than this kind
of rigid translations right and here I
try to illustrate this with a little
picture right so think about this little
uh black circle right as this as the
group of shifts right this is kind of
like a cyclic group right so here in in
this point I have the identity right
this is just not not doing anything and
then in this you know these guys
represent applying a shift
my point is that these Transformations
they exist in the broader context right
there's other things that I can do to my
image that are not in this black circle
right but somehow there are things that
I can do that are almost gem
translations right this is what I try to
illustrate with this picture right it's
like this is a this is the house right
it hasn't been completely shifted from
the original one you can see that
there's a little bit of a distortion
that is happening right things have been
moved a little bit there's a question
okay there's a question from Benjamin
that says okay
good question so let's go back to the to
the previous derivation
so Benjamin is asking about the first
step right like why is this equality
here
I guess
good this is because of this property
right that we know that because because
C is an operator that that commutes with
a shift
it necessarily has as eigenvectors all
the eigenvectors that are eigenvectors
of s right and we have seen that these
Fourier atoms
are eigenvectors of s
and so therefore there are eigenvectors
of C right so basically c times V K
transpose is equal to BK transpose times
something right and this something is
the kind of the eigenvalue of C at the
frequency k
I hope that this answers your question
Benjamin otherwise we can follow up
later offline
okay
good
perfect great okay so we are here right
and I tried I was trying to argue that
in this picture
I I couldn't I shouldn't think about the
translation group as everything there is
in my world right I can do things with
images that are not exactly translations
but they are not far right these like
these little guys here
so
in that context
I have to ask the question okay should I
ask some properties right of my
representation
do they should they treat these things
that are not exactly translations but
almost should should we try to ask
something right some kind of like a
symmetry or like almost symmetry with
respect to these guys
and so the the the point is that indeed
we can we can you know so there are a
bunch of Transformations that are that I
can apply to this big group and I can
I can Define or I can I can assign some
kind of like a distance to the to the
Symmetry group right so there are some
things that I can do to my image for
example this thing that is really at the
corner here which we all agree that is
it's a kind of a very crazy Distortion
right I'm kind of completely breaking
destroying the structure of this thing
but if I do things that are almost like
a shift right because I'm asking that
the fun the representation is invariant
to shifts well it's natural to say that
if something is very close to being a
shift maybe the representation should be
very close to being environment
okay
so that's what we are arguing here right
is that we want to think about this
notion of invariance in a bit in a more
General sense right we're going to say
that when there's a transformation Tau
that is now is living in all these black
very large space
if this transformation tau is close to
being a translation I would like the
function to be close to being invariants
right and I can quantify that with you
know kind of a cost or think about this
C of Tau that measures how close is this
transformation to being asymmetry
okay the closer it is from being a
symmetry the smaller I want this this
difference to be
okay does it does it make sense this is
an important concept
okay
and and it's an import it's important
that it's very clear for all of us right
that if I have uh you know if I have
Transformations out there that are
almost translations I want my
representation to be almost impried
okay
and these are very important concept
right because now what it means that I
cannot just think in terms of this like
little two properties that we described
like it's not sufficient to just ask for
you know pure invariants and purifics
okay
all right
so that's natural question which
convolutions are also going to help me
for this new property right this new
property that is the stability to the
formations Maybe
some of these convolutions that I
described are indeed they are equivalent
to translations but maybe some some of
these convolutions as soon as I move a
little bit away from this group they
break down completely right and maybe
some convolutions are more stable than
others
okay so that's the question
for this
[Music]
okay sorry that uh the sound so that the
motivate the kind of the justification
for for this deformation as you can
imagine it it appears in many many areas
right and there's a there's you know
examples that you can imagine uh from
computer vision right where here you
know we are kind of moving through
different periods of art uh by not rigid
translations but things that almost look
like translation right here we are
applying smooth deformations
when we think about like processing
shapes like humans humans do not move in
a way that is completely rigid right
there's things that you know that happen
between humans that are not exactly
translations and yet
we would like their our representation
to be stable right and the same thing
for molecular for molecules or for many
many areas of physics right I mean what
my point here is that the physical world
is by construction it's a world that is
stable to deformations right you don't
want any representation to be broken
just because things move a little bit
away from being a rigid signature okay
and so uh and I have I realize that I'm
a little bit late of time but this
second and third part are very very
quick right so we are hopefully going to
be done in you know in about five
maximum 10 minutes hope that it's okay
okay and so
um the the key is right is that if you
want to understand stability we should
not get too obsessed with frequency and
free right instead we should be looking
at representations that extract
information through different scales
instead of different frequencies okay
scale is a very natural it's a very
intuitive concept right it's a very
intuitive notion it's the notion
that
um you know I can look at this image and
organize the information in this image
across different resolutions right as
the as you have here right and this is
something that we touch upon a little
bit uh last week right so I can have a
version of this image that is the course
scale like a very very small number of
pixels and then every time I'm
considering what is the information that
I lost what is the information that I
need to go from one resolution to the
next right and this is what is captured
in this multi-scale representation
okay and you can actually implement this
multi-scale representation with what we
call with the various special kind of
convolutional operators that are wavelet
convolutional operators right so this is
like a these are a bunch of convolutions
right whose filter is obtained by taking
a little wave maybe this one here right
and then applying a rotation of this
wave right I'm just rotating the filter
and I'm I'm deleting the filter right so
I have basically extracting information
at different scales and orientations
and it turns out that these wavelets
have a very important property right
that you don't have in general
convolutions which is the fact that now
if I apply this wavelet this convolution
with that convolution to a
transformation that is not necessarily a
translation it's a more General
transformation then you get almost
commutation right like it's exactly the
stability that they described before
right so in particular if this tau is a
convolution you get exact equivalent as
we had before but now you get something
that is much more interesting is that if
I have a transformation Tau that is
almost a translation right measured by
the fact that this guy here is very
small then the this transformation
almost commits okay this is exactly the
stability that we described before
okay
so the punch line here the important
point right is that not all convolution
operators are stable to the formations
we need something special right for the
stability that is really brought To Us
by waves right we have something that in
technical terms it's called a kind of a
localization both in space and frequency
okay this is a kind of an important and
non-trivial result
anyway so it turns out that we with this
wavelet platforms we can define a very
simple geometric deploying blueprint
which we call this wavelet gdl right
which uh really just uses the three
building blocks of the blueprint so we
have a local local invariant which is
just a low pass filter we have a local
equilibrium that is stable which is this
wavelet filter bank and then we have a
element-wise nonlinearity which is wrong
and now we just combine these elements
uh you know exactly how the blueprint
tells us to do right so I have first one
element that is just the low pass right
this is just a linear path it is the one
here and I'm going to make it more
informative I'm going to make it richer
and I'm going to make it richer by
always systematically extracting the
information that is lost by the low path
right so I can make it richer by you
know combining this a with wavelets then
I take the you know the element-wise
non-linearity and then extract new
invariance again
and every time I extract an invariant I
can recover the information that I lost
by a new family of coefficients right
that every time that I apply a then I
complement it with you know W Times the
normal linearity right and I can keep
doing like this
so this representation is is very nice
because it can you know it has some
mathematical properties for example it
can
preserve all the energy of the signal
okay and also more importantly it's it
really has the property that we ex that
we were asking for right it's stable to
deformations in other words if I apply
this transformation to some uh deformed
version of the signal right so if Tau
here is a deformation and I compare the
difference in the scattering
coefficients like it's something that is
very close right and it depends the
distance is proportional to kind of this
deformation cost right so how far is
this Tau from being a translation
okay
anyway this representation uh you can
use it for solving many interesting
problems in physics uh and chemistry so
so here I show you some examples of how
can you use this wavelet transform to
model like some physical phenomena like
build statistical models for physical
data so this is data in you know
turbulence that is used for example in
you know in fluid dynamics this is data
that comes from glass like icing models
and this is cosmological data so you can
get build like very simple statistical
models that work pretty well okay and
cosmology chemistry Etc
it can also it can also be used for
computer vision right and so this is
really the like think about this as a
very simple blueprint right so here uh
as you can see the the we just built
this blueprint really from from first
principles right we take this input we
apply this blueprint that is the the
wavelet gdl like the wavelet scattering
and then we we do a linear
classification on that
okay and so if you look at the
performance of this model uh you know on
different kind of data sets right like
if you think of like mnist it works
pretty well but if you do it on very
more complicated problems like you know
like cfar or imagenet you see that you
know there's a little Gap right there's
a you know the the Deep Nets uh work
much better than this scatter right
and what is missing of course is that we
are you know we are just uh extracting
information uh using this wavelet
representation right in a sense there's
no you know that there's no there's no
learning here right there's no there
were no like parameters that are inside
these filters right it's just like
completely hard-coded wavelet
coefficients what is missing is the
interactions between feature Maps right
and this is really the last thing I
wanted to talk to you about today
okay and so uh one way where you can
understand like uh from from these like
wavelet scattering they're like the more
General class which are in fact uh you
know like a convolutional neural
networks is that convolutional neural
networks instead of just uh looking at
you know this wavelet decompositions and
then just passing them so non-linearity
what they can do on top is to recombine
information across feature Maps right
like a convolutional tensor right is
actually doing two things right it's
extracting information in the spatial
neighborhood right this is kind of the
spatial context of the filter but it has
something it does something much more
important which is also to recombine
information across the channels right so
it can learn how to extract information
that is kind of shared like spread
across different channels right this is
not something that you could do with the
previous representation right so if you
do this right if you if you kind of
combine the scatter like the wavelength
decomposition in space with kind of a
trainable filters and in in channels
like this kind of one by one
convolutions
then you can see that with this kind of
hybrid model you kind of recover right
up up the way to imagenet the
performance of you know uh like a more
complicated compilation in the Olympics
right
uh so the point right is that uh you
know we can use these ideas from
stability to kind of get get some grasp
on why this architectures work well
right obviously there's many things that
we don't know right and these are kind
of like the mathematics of neural
networks the convolution networks are
still pretty much under development
right
there's many things that these networks
are doing that are very important for
for example for the optimization side
like the you know the residual
connection the normalization where we
have still not a very good idea on why
how to think about those right uh
obviously there's a you know there's
some efficiency aspects right about the
um
uh you know
how large do you need to make the
network to make it work better and uh
you know here's a just a few questions
that I that I think are interesting and
uh still far from being well understood
right so in other words the geometric
deep learning blueprint we can use it to
think about convolutional neural
networks but obviously it's not
sufficient to explain all there is to
know about convolutional neural networks
right there are still some Mysteries
that we need to figure out okay like the
role of the depth even like for example
how it relates to this kind of new
architectures that are these Vision
Transformers so these are all like uh
interesting questions
so with that uh because I'm already
pretty much out of time I just want to
wrap it here okay so what uh what we saw
today is that with the grid we can uh
you know we can really play and have you
know like say precise things using kind
of the algebraic structure of the grid
like that is the you know
um obtained through it free transform
uh we can we can you know derive kind of
a convolutional network almost from
first principles right but first by
understanding uh you know the structure
of linear equivalence and then by
building these deformation stability on
top uh but of course there's many
questions that are open uh this is just
like one you know framework to think
about this but not the final answer and
then in the next lectures what we are
what you're gonna see uh you know most
the lectures from from Taco Michael and
also better is that we are going to
exactly basically apply the same
principles but on domains that are a bit
more General right so we are gonna look
at the at this blueprint how it does in
in marginal groups and also in meshes
and engaged transformations
so with that thank you very much and uh
I don't know if there's some questions
that are in campus wire or somewhere
someone has any questions
that was my last slide
okay let me check
okay thank you all uh anyway I'll be uh
checking campus wire for if there's any
other remaining questions and also let
me know if someone has any questions
with the some of the exercises that are
you know that are that have been um uh
kind of scattered through the slides
okay
uh well I cannot hear you but okay
anyway I'm gonna say bye right is
everything okay yeah bye and I hope that
you enjoy the rest of the lectures and
it was it has been a pleasure to to be
with you again this year